thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more
how are you guys doing some time ago we
made a video on this channel detailing
the suicide the excruciating suicide of
one of the individuals who was born in
the Quran in Scandinavia now the founder
of the movement has also died and this
is happening in quick succession which
reminds me of a verse in the Quran
foreign
the Allah wants to ensure that they have
no provision of the achara of the
Hereafter and they will have a painful
punishment
this individual who has established for
himself
what we can call in our terms or we can
regard from our perspective as a kind of
sadakhajaria of Marcia an individual who
is established himself
organizations plural
who burn the Quran the holy books and
now when he's in his grave all of those
sins which she's already probably being
punished for if he hasn't of course done
the shahada somehow
before he died
or something like that
whereby it can be salvific for him
that that individual will be getting a
multiplied sinful effect until the day
of judgment with a blazing fire will be
made clear for all to see what we can do
on the other hand is the exact opposite
we can give a kind of that will give us
a sadaqatonjaria a continuous charity
that will act
as that exactly which is a charity for
us make the world a better place for
Muslims in the west and in the world
make it possible for us to not be the
impossible subject in the West
strengthen our resolve give us proper
placement in the West
by aiding the biggest Masjid and Dao
Center in all of Northern Europe and all
of Scandinavia which is the Islam net
project which is already doing so well
you have done so well I'm so proud of
you the loyalists together we've been
able to raise more than a million
dollars
this is fantastic we're seeing the
fruits of this now
provision has been given to the Muslim
Community and a voice is finally being
given to us where we can fight back our
case intellectually and using all the
advantages we can acquire click the link
below and don't miss this opportunity
foreign
and whatever you spend in the course of
Allah
he will replace it and he is the best of
providers for every Salah that is prayed
in the mission five times a day
365 days a year and every little child
that memorizes the Quran and every
person who stands Ramadan from the day
the Masjid will be established and as
long as it stands you will inshallah be
sharing these unbelievable rewards so do
not let this opportunity pass you by
click the link and donate now and share
the video for even more reward
foreign
[Music]